an experience beyond limits pain and
pleasure indivisible this is the untold
truth of hellraiser
what's in a name well quite a lot when
it comes to a movie just imagine if toy
story had been called toys in the hood
alien had been called star beast or back
to the future had been called space man
from pluto because they all almost were
would these films still have gone on to
be box office smashes and critical faves
we'll never know but what we do know is
that hellraiser was very nearly called
sato masochists from beyond the grave
clive barker explained in a 1987
interview with fangoria that he
originally wanted hellraiser to have a
very different title he revealed the
imagery we're employing is as far as the
creatures from hell are concerned
something that hasn't been done before
they're like sato masochists from beyond
the grave in fact that's what i
originally wanted to call the picture as
far as titles go it's certainly a bit
beyond the pale and definitely a lot
different from the hellbound heart the
title of the novella that inspired the
film still if there was ever to be a
gang name that nailed the vibe that
pinhead butterball and the rest of the
cenobites give off sadomasocus from
beyond the grave is perfectly spot on
alongside leatherface michael myers
freddy krueger and pennywise pinhead is
an almost universally recognizable
villain and an iconic embodiment of 80s
horror it might be surprising then that
in the first hellraiser films he's not
technically a bad guy just an infernal
ambassador who takes his job extremely
seriously according to his creator
though the moniker pinhead doesn't
exactly do the character justice clive
barker explained in an interview with
dread central that the character was a
priest of hell who remained nameless in
the original script however a special
effects artist referred to him as
pinhead and that was that barker
recalled i was like wait a second you
just named my villain pinhead i didn't
think that sounded very dignified but it
ended up on the call sheet and it just
stuck who are you
before the release of hellraiser no one
realized how popular the guy with nails
in his face would end up being the hell
priest wasn't even the original poster
boy for the film pinhead actor doug
bradley told horroronline.com that a
flayed frank was originally the image
intended to grace posters and lunchboxes
at some point during production the
powers that be opted for the grid-faced
man to push the film into the darkest
corners of the public consciousness
bradley explained the image is so
original so startling it is just an
incredible image to look at and that
made a big difference in terms of the
public's perception of the movie
on one level hellraiser is a cautionary
tale about what happens to a curious
individual when he meddles in the
supernatural in another sense if you
look past the flesh flaying the screams
the carnage and the sadist with pins in
his face you'll find what clive barker
has referred to as a love story from
beyond the grave it might sound absurd
but take a closer look and you'll see
that barker isn't wrong the author
explained that just as its desire that
leads frank cotton to a lonely place
where he's skinned alive it's the same
desire that leads his brother's wife
julia cotton down the road to ruin julia
attempts to resurrect her old lover by
butchering unsuspecting men so frank can
feed on their precious blood but as
barker points out she doesn't do it
because she's a psychopath she does it
for love barker stressed in the same
interview that he intended hellraiser to
be an intelligent and popular horror
movie that didn't exploit women or
manipulate sensibilities he told
monsterland there has been a general
move towards the infantile in horror
pictures recently a desire to soften the
blows i hope this time we're going to
get tough again let's be honest the
cenobites are a pretty eye-catching
bunch if pinhead and his posse strut it
into a party it would certainly cause a
stir their look is hellish and with all
the leather and boots it's reminiscent
of the weirdest shock rock group never
to play a gig you wouldn't want to bump
into these guys in a graveyard or an s m
club the latter of which according to
clive barker is the inspiration for the
cenobite's distinctive look barker told
the guardian that both the physical and
emotional makeup of the cenobytes was
inspired by s m clubs he had frequented
specifically an underground club in new
york called block 28. barker revealed
that cell block 28 had a hardcore s m
night where there was no drinking or
drugs just intense pain pleasure and a
whole lot of piercings he elaborated it
was the first time i ever saw people
pierced for fun it was the first time i
saw blood spilt
oh no tears please
it's a waste of good suffering barker
explained that the move to make the
cenobites act and dress a certain way
was met with positive reception from the
s m community saying i was validating a
lifestyle it was a celebration of the
beauty of these strange secret rituals
having only made a couple of short films
with a group of friends in liverpool as
a teenager hellraiser was clive barker's
first experience helming a major movie
production directing a feature film for
the first time was a daunting task as he
revealed in an interview i didn't know
the rules i didn't know who the sound
guy was i only knew who the camera
operator was because he was the guy
behind the camera i don't think that
finally hurt the movie may have actually
been useful because i sort of made it up
as i went along when barker was young he
and a group of friends grabbed an eight
millimeter camera and shot two shorts
salome and the forbidden inspired by
underground and experimental directors
like kenneth anger future hellraiser
collaborators doug bradley and pete
atkins were involved in the productions
parker reflected on his work by saying
they are technically extremely crude and
their storyline's obscure actually i
think it has a strange poetry about it
that's strange poetry as well as the
themes of packs rituals killers and
sexuality have a lot in common with
hellraiser as we know it today the
puzzle box in hellraiser with which
frank opens the doors to another
dimension is integral to the franchise's
overarching plot the peculiar-looking
device also known as the lament
configuration was described in the
hellbound heart as one of several in
existence that was created by frenchman
philip lamarchon one is said to be
safely under lock and key in the
basement of the vatican another was
rumored to have been in the possession
of marquis de sade during his tenure at
the bastille and a third found its way
into the hands of an englishman named
frank
no don't touch it
it's dangerous
it opens doors
the inspiration for the puzzle box came
from an unlikely source clive barker's
grandfather according to an interview
with the podcast the geek's guide to the
galaxy barker wanted his characters to
access hell in a unique way he was
eventually drawn to a childhood memory
of an elaborate wooden puzzle box his
grandfather who was a ship's cook
brought back from the far east barker
recalled playing with the box a lot as a
child when he was puzzling about how
best his character in the hell-bound
heart could open the doors of hell he
remembered his grandfather's box and the
final piece fell into place
it's no good sweating buckets to create
a horror film designed to shock and
unnerve the audience if you pay little
attention to the soundtrack music adds
ambience atmosphere suspense and dread
to a movie in short the cenobytes can't
exactly share screen time with a disney
style soundtrack it would be terribly
unbecoming before hellraiser's release
industrial band coil delivered a
sonically charged hellscape of a
soundtrack to accompany clive barker's
film however it never made the final cut
and was replaced by christopher young's
more traditional score barker was
friendly with the members of coyle and
felt their unique sound would make a
perfect fit for hellraiser the studio
disagreed apparently deciding that the
soundtrack was just too unsettling
anyone familiar with coyle's work during
that period wouldn't have been surprised
as barker himself once said coil is the
only group i've heard on disc whose
records i've taken off because they make
my bowels churn however the truth as to
why coil's hellraiser soundtrack was
never given the green light is far more
pedestrian coils steven thrower told the
quietus that when barker asked the
producers for more special effects
funding they said something along the
lines of we didn't think this was going
to be as commercial as it is reshoot
those effect scenes and hear some more
money one stipulation we want our men to
do the score
movie sets are hectic places everyone's
got a job to do and everyone's rushing
around frantically trying not to get in
one another's way costume designers
camera operators production managers and
boom operators all play their part in a
constant effort to keep things from
going off the rails on the set of
hellraiser they also had their very own
maggot and cockroach wrangler to keep
things in order it was an odd job but a
necessary one in a pre-cgi age where
everyone had to get their hands dirty to
create something authentic in an
interview with film threat clive barker
pointed out that being on a movie set
for 14 straight hours and dealing with
30 different people all with equally
important jobs to do was far more tiring
than he had anticipated but relief came
with the insects barker enthused the
moments which were really exciting were
the major cockroach scenes which i
really liked we had a roach wrangler we
had tupperware you know the ultimate
tupperware container your roach
tupperware container in the fridge
barker explained that special passports
and visas were needed to import extra
large american cockroaches to the uk the
crew could only import male cockroaches
because there was a danger that they
could escape and procreate barker joked
somewhere in customs there's presumably
a roach sexer
although many people praised hellraiser
upon its release for breathing new life
into the horror genre not everyone was
won over by clive barker's vision famed
film critic roger ebert gave hellraiser
a paltry half star review decrying it as
a dreary sham he wrote somewhat
viciously this is one of those movies
you sit through with mounting dread as
the fear grows inside of you that it
will turn out to be feature length he
didn't care much for its sequel either
which he made clear on his tv show the
problem here is that there was no
discernible beginning middle or into
this nightmare just a series of
disconnected and gruesome scene if that
seems a tad harsh it gets worse ebert
questioned the motives of the audience
for going to see the movie in the first
place in his opinion hellraiser
contained no surprises or emotional
engagement and lacked any wit or flare
interestingly ebert's harsh verdict on
the film appeared to be the opening shot
in a war of words between the legendary
critic and clive barker as chronicled on
ebert's own website years after the
release of hellraiser barker would slam
the critic for making the controversial
statement that video games can never be
art parker described ebert as prejudiced
calling him a quote pompous arrogant old
man how much bearing ebert's notorious
review of hellraiser had on barker's
scathing words we'll never know but just
as criticism is always subjective an
artist never forgets a bad review
imagine pinhead and michael myers
battling it out in a cinematic crossover
along the lines of freddy vs jason or
alien vs predator and then imagine it
some more because it's never going to
happen however it nearly did although it
probably wouldn't have contained a lot
of small talk between the chief cenobite
and the masked murderer hellraiser vs
halloween was a promising premise
nevertheless paul kane's book the
hellraiser films and their legacy
reveals that filmmaker dave parker once
pitched the idea of a crossover event to
dimension films parker needed a way to
get the two villains together for a
rumble so he hatched an origin story in
which myers is trick-or-treating as a
child and receives a mysterious box from
a stranger in black boots upon opening
it the lord of the dead possesses
meyer's body and goes on a killing spree
since he's possessed by a demonic entity
myers cannot be killed until pinhead
shows up years later from there it's
game on dimension was excited enough to
reach out to both clive barker and john
carpenter and penciled in a release date
of october 31st 2004 however not only
did the owners of the halloween movie
rights throw shade on the idea a poll on
the official halloween website suggested
that the majority of fans didn't want
the movie to happen so it didn't
one of the most unsettling things about
the cenobytes apart from their
insatiable desire to inflict pain is
their unnerving silence unwavering eye
contact with unreadable yet intense
facial expressions combined with the art
of keeping your entire body extremely
still is the embodiment of psychological
intimidation the cenobites are obvious
masters at it with the exception of
pinhead who's not exactly mr talkative
the rest of the cenobites and hellraiser
are a pretty mute bunch even the
chatterer isn't much of a chatterbox in
total pinhead is only in the original
film for eight minutes and doesn't have
a lot of lines that's why it's no wonder
that combined with the industrial makeup
doug bradley thought he would be
unrecognizable in character in an
interview with the guardian bradley
explained that he was offered both the
role of pinhead and the bit part of a
moving man he had reservations about
playing a heavily made up monster saying
because hellraiser was my first movie i
thought it might be a good idea to be on
screen as myself but it was a brief
conversation there was no doubt in my
mind that this unnamed guy with the pins
in his head had a certain genesecua that
a mattress delivery guy didn't the first
time bradley saw himself in the mirror
as pinhead he knew he had made the right
decision he continued i had a sense of
majesty his threat is implied look what
i did to myself now imagine what i can
do to you
trick us again child
and your suffering will be legendary
even in hell
[Music]